hey this is Jackson Wang and here are
all the snacks that I would die for
[Music]
oh my God in Chinese it's a childhood
snack it's called thought by two it's
been around for like millions of years
you know and every time as a kid you
would just walk past a shopping mall
it's just like everywhere when you eat
it the first time it feels like
a Milkman just slapped you in the face I
would have this in my house my mom knows
that I love him I would eat them every
time after a meal before the meal
anytime
the Milkman is here that by two actually
means the Big White Rabbit so if you
ever get a chance to visit China
this is it search for the rabbit
bam this is as you can uh see it's
called Uh sunflower seeds it's first of
all this is so good it comes in like
like this you think to yourself before
you eat this you're like okay you know
what there's so many of them I'm gonna
have three and to a certain point your
arms your your hands are not listening
to you and you just finished that whole
thing everyone will eat this you know
talking with friends at night you're
Gathering watching movies drinking
this would just be on the table people
know how good you are so if you're a pro
you just crack it
oh another one give me another chance
if you're a pro you it's crack it
I don't know what you do and then you
spit out
maybe I'm not the best example but hey
I'm not an amateur so there are levels
and they judge you
you call this in Chinese Senza
and again this is one of those snacks as
a kid you have no idea what it is and
you're just there on the table and
you're like Mom what is this and they're
like you shut up just eat it can
somebody tell me what this is made out
of though I'm just gonna call my mom and
ask Hawthorne it's made out of Hawthorne
foreign
describe the taste of it apple with
sugar I would say you know they come in
different sizes the other ones that I
have it's almost like a pile of tokens
boom yes all right see you bro
this one that looks like a pile of token
and
growing up back home it's the thing that
we would go for it's one of like top
five that's like an upgrade version but
this is like the original boom
it was just on the table and as a kid I
love these it's made out of like flour
egg and like syrup I guess these are
like so good it comes in
like this
um
childhood
[Music]
you have the texture of the brownie The
Taste is like a cake like a cookie yeah
it's not that sweet
just right how frequently am I eating
this
um not frequently but it's one of those
that you when you see it when you bump
into it you're like ah it's like you
know seeing your family member like your
aunt your uncle you don't travel with
them you're not with them every day but
when you see it you just feel you just
feel home
this my best cereal first pick
[Music]
after becoming a singer performer I
travel around the world every place I go
I would buy like the Loco cereal which
were great but you know one of my best
best best best best best best best best
zero is this
it's not too sweet it's crunchy
oh man
I think you know I'm a fan of like milk
it's almost like the thought by two I
mean it's it's like that milky and I
feel like this cereal does not interfere
with the relationship between the cereal
and the milk it keeps like its distance
nothing can beat this at this moment
thank you
this is Rice Krispies it's a gift and a
curse it's like you tried one you can
not have two you try to you cannot not
have three the thing about this is you
you can make them at home and when you
make them it comes it's this fake and
you just finish everything
I can't believe everyone loves this
right yeah no why is why is everyone
like shaking their heads
this is the best every time on set when
I'm like shooting every time it's here
how can anyone not fall in love with
this
leave a comment if you're not a fan of
this man
hey guys again this is Jackson Wang and
thank you so much for watching me you
know sharing my childhood snacks and the
snacks that I would die for and also
make sure to check out my new album
magic man it's the process of me finally
you know becoming who I am now everybody
could be their form of Magic Men Please
please
check it out
[Music]